what is going on guys welcome to the
next part of our kellner channel
tutorial mini series within our python
mathematics and finance finance finance
indicators uh last video i was telling
you all about the kellner channel and
this one we're actually going to go
ahead
and program it into python
so if you don't already have a lot of
the data uh we're gonna need two things
actually three things now because i
decided to make you guys's lives even
easier if you don't have the sample data
uh go to centex.com hover over
about us click on uh tutorials i think
there's also a link there'll be a link
in the description to head here
uh we'll click on this and i'll take you
to this page here
uh and here you need basically we're
gonna actually
make quite a few stops uh we need
average true range we want the code for
that so
we'll go ahead and grab the code from
there
and make sure that it didn't get messed
up so my little code poster thing it
likes to uh switch out the greater than
and less than signs
with a like url encoding for it it's
very annoying
so next thing we want that you want to
get the
starting code for our calculation videos
and then also you're going to want your
sample data
and then we'll eventually get the other
code but
the first thing we've got average true
range here and we want to pull the
sample code which
is here let me make sure yeah see like
we have the
less than or eight let me fix that right
now all right let's try again
and yes okay so i fix them now uh so the
first thing we'll want to do
is actually we won't even need that
other thing since right here
so what we can do is just copy and paste
this entire uh code for atr because we
really we need atr so we're gonna make a
few changes to this code
but atr is really an integral part to
the keltner channel so we might as well
just copy and paste all of that
and actually that's the only thing we
need to copy and paste because
um
the rest will be coding ourselves now
for now and in the next video we'll get
the other code that we need
so this is the data we need and let's
just go ahead and make sure it works
let's run this
uh make sure you also have the sample
data and everything lined up
uh if you don't have the sample data uh
you'll want to grab that as well and
save that
to like just copy and paste all this and
save that
uh to sampledata.txt basically this file
right here because that's what it's
referencing
okay so we got tr working now so now we
actually want to
uh work on the calculation of
um well first we should kind of fix
atr because i don't really like the way
it's looking at the moment maybe we'll
actually replace the current
example of atr with this one um
so we want to have like one big grand
atr
function first of all and also let's
move exponential moving average
uh to the top here
then let's define
atr because it worked fine like this
kind of worked fine when all we wanted
to do is plot an atr
but when we want to use atr in another
formula
it this just becomes like a huge massive
mess and just not a very good way to do
it
so uh we'll fix that so anyway uh
tab everything over now so we've got a
nested function you know
so once you've done that let's go ahead
and
comment that out we don't need to print
that anymore
and the rest of this should be fine for
now
we don't need this anymore and we print
atr now we can actually
uh have this return
the atr cool
so that should be all the modifications
actually yeah let's uh we need to pass
that through
and uh
we need to pass through atf
and that should be it okay because the
regular time frame is just for
exponential moving average
so that's good okay we'll find out soon
enough if we're um
massively screwing up so now what we're
going to do is we're going to find
celt to create these keltner channels
and kel is only going to need two things
tf and atf um atf just stands for
another time frame
so that's what that's all about let me
make some space
okay so now we're gonna have this
function is gonna return
three lines basically so the first line
will be ul for upper line the second
line will be ml for middle line the
third line will be ll for lower line
next we're gonna say atr equals
atr and then we're going to go ahead and
copy and paste all of these values
because that's what we're passing
through right
so copy and paste those from above and
then also we have to paste in
or push through atf
atf applies to our atr
um so if you can't remember that's a
good way to remember it just in case for
your uh
for your final uh your final exam here
at centex university
good study tips now what we want to do
is tfema equals x
moving average
and the prices we want to use close
prices and the time frame is tf
next we're going to say tfema it's one
digit too long
because it's not going to match uh our
exponential moving average so
or our date rather anyway tfema really
needs to be
one colon so
uh tf ema equals tfema1
colon all set next x
equals zero next wow x wow
x is less than the length of tfdma
what in the heck do we want to do well
we're going to say
um current um
upper line equals tf ema
x plus and if you recall it was two
times
atr x
now i'm just going to copy and paste
this and make the necessary
modifications
so paste paste this will be a minus
down here this won't even exist here
current
middle line current lower line
awesome and in fact uh i'll do
another solid i forgot to zoom in when i
started actually typing stuff
so we'll do that now and if you feel
like you're behind or something
pause it here and this is a good little
frame to catch up
next um what we want to do
is uh ul dot append
uh curio and we're gonna say ml.open.
uh caramel not to be confused with
caramel
ll.append
now uh x plus equals one
we've exhausted that while loop when we
have done that we want to return ul
mll finally ul
ml ll equals
kelt and we want to use a 20 and a 10
for our moving
or our time frames and um
that's about it that's all we need to do
so just to see that we've
succeeded or successfully done something
let's just print ul and see what happens
okay so we printed out some other stuff
probably for atr
but this is our upper line
and the numbers look to be somewhat
legitimate since
uh it should just be plotting right
above uh the price and we're using
starbucks here as their sample data
and so those prices look normal so now
we believe we are ready to go ahead and
port this over to our charting
application and plot this bad boy up
so that's what we'll be doing in the
next video as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time